this program features live coverage of
an African safari and may include animal
kills and caucuses viewer discretion is
advised
what a great afternoon to start with
look at the predetermined one of the
water holes and the Impala is drinking
there he doesn't know what to do is
looking at the Impala is facing the
wrong direction a very very good
afternoon and welcome to the beginning
of our afternoon Safari and my plan is
quite very easy this afternoon I will be
looking for the cats
my name is Sydney from Iran my cozy and
for incase if you need our attention you
can follow us on Twitter hashtag Safari
live you can also follow us on YouTube
chat stream so what is happening here is
unusual you can see we've got
amphitheatre right in the middle of the
water hole and the Impala is directing
behind and this Impala before he got
here it did not even check if there is a
predator or not he was just considering
she was concentrating much more on the
surrounding and went straight to that
side so the hyenas mostly we see them
active at night but I can promise you
Highness we do see them a lot doing
their movements during the day
specifically if they say kill around you
will see them going in order to have a
chance to have something to eat now the
Highness in the middle of the waterhole
because the Sun is very hot at the
moment she also try to cool the
temperature a bit but don't get
surprised because sometimes - early in
the mornings and late afternoons they
normally go to the waterhole before even
the Sun comes out in the morning and
they play by the water holes sometimes
they also do mud wallow away
indeed this is a pool day you can see
that earlier on from the dam cam I saw
the elephants we are also having a seam
and it was quite a lot of them
youngsters were enjoying now we have got
the Heine so now I am going to fly you
to the Maasai Mara in Kenya before David
lose his sighting is gonna bed at the
moment fun tastic Sydney and a very warm
welcome to the Mara triangle and we
starting with a feathered friend there
land that's a tawny Eagle and she's just
either warming herself I don't know why
she should be that's pretty warm for me
because we're talking about 34 degrees
and 93 degrees Celsius my name is David
and on camera today is Bungay it won't
be a very good afternoon welcome all of
you and remember this is a very
interactive Safari should you have any
questions or any comments talk to us
hushed a pacified life on Twitter all
right back to our rafter there and that
he's a bird of prey will call them
Raptors because of what they're able to
do
Raptors coming from a large Latin word
repel would you mean like something to
say or something to forcefully hold the
cell ruptures in Raptors are very many
is any bird that maybe will be able to
grasp or hold another one for safely to
prey on it
a lot more you are right those talents
are no joke and Bungay is giving you the
best from this ego here and they need
those talents that are huge and strong
because they pick sometimes lumps and
baby
antelopes for example or when they need
to kill other buds they need them very
much their legs also happen to be very
strong and if you look on the big the
big is very hooked and very sharp at the
end it's like a dagger so they need
strong legs and the talent should be
able to dig in any prey they pick up to
fly with it if they do not feed on it on
the ground
Tony he grows a very similar to the
stepper he go the difference very the
step ego have the yellow line you see
below the eye there is little extended
towards the back or towards the ears of
the typical characteristic all egos
having feathered legs apart from the
snake he goes I think most snake he goes
will not have any offenders well I'll be
moving on but in the meantime I want to
take you back to Sydney to see what kind
of predator he still got I am still here
with the relaxed hyena by the water all
at the moment we saw the Impala coming
to drink which means maybe Ines are not
considered a very strong set threat by
this animal such as impalas but I think
that Impala did not notice that it was a
hyena here until she left I saw her
running seemed like she realized only
her way out
so look at those beautiful ears Judy it
is normal for this kind of predators to
be here at the waterhole for this long
this clan the Jew MacLean normally they
used to go to the tree house damn and
also the twins them and spend much time
just by the waterhole specifically at
the edge where is mud you will see them
with mud this is normal but now here
where I am in the western side of the
greater Kruger National Park Service and
Juma Game Reserve the Sun is at 34
degrees is quite very hot at the moment
I'm not surprised why is he spending
much time in that waterhole at the
moment
quite a very difficult name for me to
pronounce and I will get the name as I
am explaining about the waterhole this
whatever it is indeed a man made what I
will learn is a difficult fun
so this whatever it is a man-made
waterhole you can see that these at the
edges there you can see that we are
refilling every time when the water is
taking away the soil and also the branch
is there to prevent animals from opening
for the water to flow down the other
side
but if you can check the design of the
water all met all the requirements what
ours are not just design for animals to
come and drink there is lot of things
which has to be considered for example
there has to be available cover for in
case if the Predators wants to hide that
is very much important so if you can
check here the water vole does have some
hiding areas for the Predators to be
able to act they must have to also be
bushes for the Predators and animals to
go and rest after drinking so what I old
does influence the natural life where
animals can hide for others to come to
and drink and other animals after
drinking can also hide under the shade
a safari sorry
the hyenas I have never seen them
swimming by the very deep water every
time I see them to the areas where you
can see the whole body you can see the
big part of the body shoving out if you
look here and now you can see that only
the bottom part is public on the ground
and you cannot see the stomach but from
the side of the stomach up you can see
this animal so if you look at the neck
the neck doesn't have spot so if you
don't check properly it's difficult to
even tell that designer has got spots
it's like it doesn't expose at all all
the Highness if you check them here by
the neck it did the honor spotted the
spots are only around the bodies
so now let's go to the Alliance one of
those animals who are seen fighting with
Highness for food mostly good afternoon
everybody welcome to the Mara triangle
in Kenya my name is Steve I'm joined on
camera by big James at a beautiful 28
degrees cells is 82 degrees Fahrenheit
it's a wonderful afternoon to search for
cats it's not hot
there could be lions moving they could
be hiding in the shade we checked this
area this morning all the way down that
side we checked this air and our arts
all the way back to camp we didn't find
there we no pride so what we gonna do is
we get up ahead there's a road that
takes us to the scope and Road again and
we're gonna go sort of south a long
matter maybe we'll be lucky and spot
something in the form of cats that to be
wonderful
that is objects for the afternoon we
weren't able to find him this morning Oh
yesterday but today we are going to try
and find the or we know pride the pride
of five individuals very recognizable by
the adults one adults is quite pale in
color and the young male is also very
pale with a very nice or very
interesting injury on the inside of his
back of his left hip which is healing
quite nicely but there's an abundance of
zebra and buffalo food this area and
well we did check this side this morning
but we didn't find anything so maybe on
the right hand side we'll be able to
find something in the form of a know we
know Linus
which we wonderful I would like to find
them for you and of course along the way
who knows what else for your fun
there'll be there'll be birds and there
will be there'll be the wonders of the
wild so please send your questions
through hashtag Safari lab drop your
questions or comments we'll saw in the
YouTube chat stream we'd love to hear
from you let us know if you have any
queries or suggestions for the afternoon
that you'd like to discuss on this
wonderful Sunday afternoon it is very
hot start and juma and while we are
blessed with a pretty average sort of
temperature humor the winners are indeed
the underdog pride I need to lioness
they were essentially a break away from
the sausage tree pride which david has
been spending a lot of time with of late
and well they're trying to make their
mark art yet and well you can see the
zebras are everywhere at the moment lots
of rain has been falling along this
escarpment over the last couple of weeks
and well the grazing is phenomenal it's
not as tall as when I came a month and a
half ago when the thousands upon
thousands of animals moved through here
in pretty much mode right down the the
living lawnmower service but they are
still in place they've come back more
zebra here than when I got back from my
leave two weeks ago and the Buffalo know
everywhere elephants are in huge in
abundance and well all we need to do is
between all of that is scratch out some
lions but importantly what is it that
provides the ability for lions to stay
in this environment and why do Lions
form prides and well these interesting
topics of discussion obviously lions
being a savanna hunting specialists
prides develops due to the large prey
items that developed when the Savannah
opened up and created what they're ekend
200 times more animal species than what
the forest would have allowed before all
the different feeding regimes all the
different grazing heights the different
browsing heights has a lot for an
enormous number more mammal species than
the
previously Willie the grasses are
suppose they do smell quite nice quite
fragrant almost like a very nice
Sauvignon Blanc lots of people like to
describe some beyond Blanc is a
fresh-cut grass which if you happen to
find yourself close to the nose of a
zebra while feeding you'd probably get
that crisp fresh note on the nose which
just made me rather thirsty on this
Sunday afternoon I'm sure that hyena Don
and juma wouldn't mind a cold beverage
while cooling down in the pan and while
animals that don't need to cool
themselves down too much not far away
from us david Guiteau is with a very
tall giraffe
all right let's have a little change and
look at this tall animals of the African
plains of the African bushes and these
are the Messiah giraffes and sometimes
they'll forget to use the advantage of
the height and just go for some bushes
that are pretty low from the ground like
the Kapus bush and they'll always be
picking on the leaves from those bushes
giraffes being browsers they will not be
bothered to eat any grass smaller leaves
twigs and that's nothing apparently
which is quite something
well done boom gain I was wondering what
that young calf was doing and just
realized she's nothing what a position
to be in there yeah I mean the final
controls is pretty awesome because I
don't remember the last time I saw ups
come on mama the mother was not very
amused she thinks he's time for her to
start feeding on you know to be weaned
and sat eating the normal food but that
was pretty cool to see a giraffe just
nothing there I mean see how tall the
mother is and when they give birth and
I'm assuming this is definitely her baby
they drop the babies from such high
height Sharon I'm happy for your comment
because even for me I'm trying to walk
back and remember the last time Sharon I
saw a giraffe nothing and it's a long
time zebras we see every day Lions
especially the Cubs we see almost every
other day pattern I don't remember the
last time I saw giraffe and this peak
because look look at that baby she is
almost the same size as the mother you
know she is big half there
she should you know be feeding on the
leaves like the rest so that's kind of
Bush is what I guess he should be
feeding on which is saying if I'm only
maybe baby of the mother who I don't I
keep enjoying the milk notice she's a
bit lighter in color than the mother of
course one because of young age but not
necessarily we get some giraffes that
are duck even when they are young
depending on their genetics different
types of giraffes in East Africa this
one being the Masai giraffe we have
another species that you called
articulated Kristine good question do
female giraffes fight asked the mayor's
do out say no Christine they might have
little squabbles here and there but I
would say Christine male or female
giraffes do not get into that combat
like the mayors and it should be about
two months ago initial Christine you had
or you saw we had two mil drafts that
fought to death which was quite unusual
if you get two giraffes mil fighting one
will always die and maybe the winner
survives but in this particular case
this is about two months ago we had to
merge drafts and they fought it to death
and that's why when you look on top of
the ossicones
or the horns on top of the giraffes the
males one I always blunt or bold or flat
because they're always engaging
themselves in combats once a while
sometimes for mating rights you know
sometimes they wanted a younger ones or
the losers to submit to them and of
course if you want to be the dominant
male you must prove to the other males
why you should be in charge
so it gets the drums I then think it's
like that or sometimes way about an open
area while they'll be getting some
leaves and other small bushes hello
there pretty tall animals and having
three different or four different
species of giraffes in Africa everything
else is the same apart from the body
pattern that's only the thing that would
change and see them looking differently
lifespan gestation period you know size
as much as the little later giraffe a
little taller to me than this one's here
and again remember this is a very
interactive Safari Drive that we do keep
talking to us questions comments twitter
using hashtag safari live Chris good
snow I'll tell you ideally drafts to me
I could be wrong and maybe my friend
sensitive might want to disagree with me
Chris I have found out giraffes are the
most careless mothers to turn off when
we talk a big animals like this
I think drops really don't care the
times you see a giraffe and a mother and
a calf like almost a kilometer two
kilometers away which doesn't make much
sense because they expose them and make
them very vulnerable to would-be
predators
you know scratch their on the back I do
not know where the Ox because our Oxford
has the types of bars that will come and
remove the mites and the ticks that was
a big scratch she kept scratching
very good good and still met from the
Messiah drops he will take you again
across to South Africa to Sydney and
find out what he is up to with his
Highness so there is still very much
stationary at the moment here not only
the hyena is trying to avoid the Sun at
the moment here where I am I just want
to show you somewhere something else
from a distance also is under the tree
since we have arrived here you can see
there we have got a small head of the
elephants they are also under a very big
mullah tree they have been there for
quite a while now so it means that 34
degrees Celsius I have indicated earlier
it is giving this animal some sunburn
this afternoon so what I'm going to do
now is that I will be heading towards
the heat watch it WA area as I have been
updated earlier on that the Lions has
been spotted earlier around that area I
want to go and see which pride is that
and then later on we'll come back here
and see if we can find the spotted cast
on if it was here it was he going to
change the Highness sometimes they do
chase each other sometimes no this I
know sometimes can be very much ignorant
to us on they come and they look at him
and after you see them looking at him
like this when he is trying to open the
mouth to show his aggression they just
turn and go so asana by this time of the
day mostly is when he is resting he will
come to drink soon as the Sun starts to
cool down but possibilities of the
interactions are very high but hyenas
are not that very much afraid of asana
at the moment maybe as time goes wrong
when Hassan is starting to gain a lot of
strength and to try and show that he can
fight there will be some lot of
challenges to the Highness
so he's listening to the impalas at the
background who are also coming to drink
Isabella
indeed this aina looks so relaxed not
worried is just listening to what is
happening don't get surprised when
hearing other vehicles engines I am NOT
alone at this beautiful sighting there
are other people here with me but I am
going to leave this relaxed Hina now and
see if we can find maybe we might be
lucky with those lions when we get to
the chitwa chitwa area later on I will
come back here and see if we can find
this potted cats but before I come here
I will try to drive the cheetah cutline
just try to see if we can be lucky with
Kangana Horta llama in that area later
on I will also visit the Hina then if
the time is still available for us to do
so so I am the only one out at the
moment so I will be driving a lot
visiting different areas
so now let's cross over back to Steve by
the Maasai Mara who is still with the
Lions
apologies for that technical error when
it comes to signals I am now making my
way to the shiitake to Adam I'm just
gonna pass by The Jackal berry tree
where wasana was hiding some mill
yesterday and the day before this
morning I also got some update that
Hassan took a small baboon and he ran
away towards one of these areas chased
by those baboons some baboons they can
be so very protective
nothing is left only a small bits of the
intestine is ending their that I'm not
seeing anything too much so I'm just
gonna check here by the damn wall
because sometimes from the top I can be
able to spot any professor lay down
somewhere here now I'm not seeing him
now let him let me give him some time I
will come back when we first go to
chitwa chitwa we might be lucky with him
when we come back
actually I didn't get your question very
well here the question is related to the
Hina in water
the therapy in the possibilities oh look
at this this Impala here I can see the
stomach is very very big it's so heavily
pregnant might deliver at any time maybe
that is one of the reasons why this
Impala is isolating yourself from the
others if you look at that body now you
can see so the baby can arrive here at
any time this week
so the cherry pain possibilities of the
cherub in to pick up some of the things
and not from the body of the Heine but
of the INA because when the Hina is
there now yes possibilities of some of
the tics to come off they are very much
high so I'm sure Hina
because you cannot see under water if we
get touched by something else you must
have to go out
I don't think he will allow the Terrapin
to touch him when it's under the water
there
so now let's go back to David who is
looking for the Alliance at the moment
well my plants are being to also look
for lions like Sydney but as much as he
is going to cheated on me should he not
even get Lions cheated Amazonas full of
activity and on my way to the Lions I'm
thinking of looking for today
Hamish into these old guests should be a
male elephant not very far from the mass
area and you can tell he's just feeling
on that nice green grass
this area has underground water and even
times when you have big drought the
grass here remains very green and you
have seen so many animals crowding this
one small area during difficult times of
drought in the Mara Triangle male floors
be on their own all right
having my elephant just eating I think
we got elephants could be doing
something interesting well thanks David
we have indeed got elephants here two
bulls that we're having a little bit of
a pushing shoving match and the typical
typical sort of behavior that an
elephant does once it's been dominated
or sort of displacement behaviour to
show that it's being subordinate is they
turn their shoulder like the one on the
right hand side it was being pushed it
had decided no I don't like that typical
behavior when one elephant is dominant
than the other one often you'll see a
big bull walking into a group and one of
the younger ones will just turn away
like that one on the right and there's a
very good sign of one being submissive
and well they were having a bit of a
pushing shoving match and it wasn't very
serious but one of the rights is
obviously smaller and didn't quite like
the attentions of the bigger male and
well we've got some Buffalo as well
lying up in the in the open no I think
they're lying up some are lying up those
are standing in fact the grass is
very long over there the preferred
habitat of Buffalo nice long juicy
grasses
do you like nutrient-rich grasses as
well here we go we've got a couple lying
up enjoying a bit of a rumination this
afternoon no doubt if it was as hot as
it is in Juma they'd probably be lying
up in the mud keeping themselves nice
and moist and cool and yes the blood
serves a secondary purpose the mud I
mean of keeping the flies away and a
third purpose of your a decay ting any
parasites in the form of ticks that they
might have but let's have a look at
these two bulls and see exactly if
they're going to get up to new nonsense
again
seems as if the shenanigans is now over
and they're going off on to their
feeding but it's time for play when you
have the requirements of so much food
per day that elephants generally haven't
big males enormous amounts Scottie
they're not hiding they're basically
just having a bit of a chill they've
probably been feeding for a period of
time and now they're all just lying down
taking a break resting their tired legs
while those two are not they're still
feeding very inquisitive and looking at
us and the others are resting so when
they're certain and ruminate so they're
actually resting they're meditating
their bodies are resting because they
are not using their legs
so they taking up the weight and while
their mind is in a state of meditation
very automatic response and it's for
that reason that ruminants don't
necessarily actually sleep let's just
ruminate and get up and feed and then
ruminate and get up and feed it's a
constant constant battle Harsha between
rest and feeding our simple would life
be if we were able to eat grass and get
everything we needed simple would it be
so simple plenty of grass around
Emma says as long as we can put some
form of address ting on it yes well
these animals get by eating quite dry
sometimes quite under Jess table sorts
of food but out here in the Mara
especially after the rains these grasses
you can see your odd buffalos legs are
some brown patches and then green
patches now essentially what that is
I've got some in the grass on the
dashboard for you here so we can have a
little look-see and see what's going on
and it is in fact the red grass or the
red oat grass known as red grass in
South Africa the thermi to try Andhra
you can kind of see the remains of sort
of the inflorescence there you can see
which one that one over there just see
the three sort of try Andhra there we go
it's kind of fading because the grass
went the reproductive stage produced its
seeds and they've probably fallen on the
floor somewhere and the brownness if I
just pulled this grass out you'll see
I've grabbed an entire piece of the
grass yet and where the grass grows so
here is the base here is the roots and
that's anchored in the ground obviously
a lot of the nutrients can be stored in
there and the roots are designed for
picking up the nutrients derived from
this very nutrient-rich soil and the
rainfall facilitates that and then the
grass will grow and what we can see in
parts of a Ches sorry James I've made a
mess of this let me just grab this piece
yet what we can see here is the new
growth growing out over here so there's
some old growth over here from earlier
the season and then you can see the new
growth is popping out yeah that's what
the the Buffalo are absolutely loving
right now a zebra is well quite enjoying
that so a second growth for this grass
of this season being a perennial grass
they'll be around for more than one
season and I know you're all wanting me
to try it yes that's very
hmm it's not bad
there's as Emma says it could probably
do with the dressing could probably do
with the dressing and the idea of behind
the ruminant is to to be able to chop
that up and chew that up to be able to
maximize ya know it's a maximize this
grass into small little particles for
digestion and Rubina you want to know
how much grass the average Buffalo can
eat I actually have absolutely no idea
um hmm so I've got a few bits of grass
stuck in my mouth I actually have no
idea Rubina another Buffalo can drink
about 30 odd 40 odd litres of water per
day
well they require two and the grass well
they need I'm gonna find out I'm gonna
find Ruby them I'm sure I can find it
somewhere but I don't know at the moment
but if they means I'm a David he's found
so there you play for young elephants
I think it's gonna be a very good day
today for Elly's the first mullah hard
and Steve had tools were like going for
each other and have found breathing hard
with this young master here showing us
how much he can eat and how efficient
she is picking the grass there see very
similar to what you call coach grass and
I've always wondered what an elephant
can do without a trunk a very important
organ to elephants these are the African
elephants and most of the Savannah
elephants they're different from what
sometimes we call the forest elephant it
just in terms of size walking away there
see how majestic when they walk if it
approached the grass doesn't come out
the Lord is giving a small little kick
with the leg and they're very cute
sometimes the pig choosing just the
green one you can see not just sometimes
just grasping grass for the sake of
grasping grass they of course want to
the right cross the right neutrons and
what I wanted to do is just have a
little change a little change of the
angle because we have another one that
has a car here
I think boom gave want us to shoot that
one can I keep coming away
keep coming keep coming
it's good and this one seems a modern hi
young one what guests could be less than
25 years it's still not asked that are
showing up and you can see the
characteristic pose for elephant when
the rest and the lift up one leg you
just put it back much for the young ones
just eating was just being full of
nonsense and protein grass and kicking
it see all the wrinkles on the trunk
very nice and I'm guessing the only what
about 15 meters from where we are and so
long as this animals you kind of behave
yourself you're not very loud not you
know the hinges are running you can have
the best time with elephants which
happen to move my favorite animals of
all the animals that we got in Africa
furtive close to mama what a short how
nice is that
cynic good Christian we are talking
about underground water you see that
elephant there and you can tell he seems
to like to be wearing some socks that
shoes he was she was wallowing at one
point and the short rains have not come
very well out she's in a car at the
moment and still dry and some rivers and
streams have dried up but of course not
the marsh area as was talking in before
and the other day I've found some
elephants that's wet to river and been
intelligent as they are they will always
tell like hydrologist we are two source
for water and elephants using the trunks
and tusks and legs dragged about three
feet and the probably water popped up
and I'll tell you cynic that water
should be also good for human beings it
was out on a drive in our forgotten my
water and I was thirsty cynic out
definitely drink that water must be very
clean and very sifted by this hand one
more time to say goodbye to these
elephants before we move on
and I think there were different areas
so we're gonna be moving on to Seoul's
full other stuff all right
elephants get insane Daniel say what's
about the mom sorry
and there was an elephant trumpeting
behind me there
Oh Daniel I get your comment and you
think the mom is quite small and most
likely Daniel guests that could be maybe
how fast cough and from what is so she
looked pregnant again so if she's about
three they might take four or five years
before they get another baby but in
terms of science I agree with you
she looked a very small mama and was
like they're grabbing half half a scarf
it would happen for such small cows
anything nine to ten years Daniel you
know cows are fully grown and mature and
sexually mature and you could easily you
know just get a calf we have another one
here which also looks to be another
young cow and let's try to compare this
to the very first one is so quite a
number of them and breathing hard that
oh so Daniel looks like a young cow with
a calf - but if boom baby is suing to
the left there's another hand and
there's one fully grown of big female
that seems to have one task excellent
thank you very much she's very big cow
Christian good question how old must the
you know the cuffs be before the mothers
get pregnant again I would say anything
for five years should be a good agent in
for five years should be a good age
before the mother can get pregnant again
I mean he's such an investment graceful
a cow to carry a baby for like two years
so they want to do the best they can you
see that one put it on the trunk up they
won't through the best they can to make
sure that baby matures they have worked
so hard for two years carrying that baby
going through the labor so they have to
take some time until they're guaranteed
that the baby can survive on its own
before they can conceive again I'm sure
we all know among the animals in the
wilderness the elephant's got the
mammary glands between the four legs
when the people will always miss that
point as Bungay is showing you there we
have seen viewers seeing calves nothing
and wondering what those comes a drink
and we tell them they are nothing and
they're like the nothing at the wrong
place but yes that's where the glance or
the mummies of the female car of the
female elephants are so many reasons to
not have the other tasks could be a
genetic reason sometimes age sometimes
when they bring down bushes or trees
they crack them and of course once they
lose them that's it they are left with
one and as the ER looks very toned so I
would say this is a very senior citizen
from the Luke
she's quite mature cow
the right ear looks fine and the times
are made jokes saying the African
elephants ears look like the map of
Africa and the ones for Asia to click
the map of Asia but not exactly so we
don't say that when you have kids with
us on the show but one thing is a fact
both males and females here have tusks
a lot more you're talking about carving
and depending on the animals we are
looking at and comparing the difference
between here and juma elephants to me
will breed all around a year they'll
have babies all around there but should
we look of different species of animals
like the wildebeest they have a
particular season that will bring down
the babies and that will be the month of
February and that mainly would be in
Serengeti east of Serengeti in Tanzania
the Western gongura conservation area in
Tanzania but the wildebeest that's
happened not to go or tag along with
them during the migration that remain
here in Kenya they apparently get babies
in the same time so around February both
wildebeest and you know in Kenya and in
Tanzania
they'll have babies at that particular
time but elephants and giraffes and all
the other animals will have babies or
around the very lucky
elephants can adopt to eat both grass
and bushes like mixed feeders it's very
difficult to see elephants it's
traveling of hunger because they'll
always have a lot they have much choices
of what to feed on
that's a very good question and it has
been claimed or you want some elephants
whether they have twins it has been
claimed they do personally I'll tell you
for a fact of my all my years in the
bush I have never seen an elephant with
twins but it is very possible most of
the animals here will always get one
calf one baby with a rhinos elephants or
even the antelopes took of the
wildebeest zebras but it has been
claimed that occasionally they get twins
I have never seen an elephant when the
twin boomy have you seen one our
suburban guy says he hasn't seen one as
the majestically walk across the road in
front of us
and I'm guessing that calf definitely
that is the mother
following the footsteps of mom the most
a very behind occasionally get pretty
Ted by Lions Lions will always hunt any
animal II think could offer them an
opportunity
as I was saying before it should be for
a number of reasons looking at it on a
genetical point the elephant that are
born with one task and the elephants
that are also born with zero tasks not
even one but also the use of the tasks
either to fight to dig for water to
bring you know food down when they're
breaking the bring the branches that
could be another reason to lose the
other task as we get old is a supposed
to both masters that all the tasks to
get we can maybe lose it or it could
have been an infection so all these
possibilities could cause this
particular le to have only one task
sometimes we say elephants either
right-handed or left-handed and if this
particular ones right-handed and kept
using the 100 so much that could be
another reason
Tian where as much as the tusks of
elephants keep growing the alike made of
keratin protein just like a human hair
or nails and they keep growing all their
lives very majestic they got very padded
foot if you would be like lying next to
the grass not elephant unless you listen
carefully
you might not even get the vibration as
she walks and a three beautiful MCS and
the background of the trees and the
different shades of green there or
well-done Bungay either to me she is
pretty big female and at the very fool
and not sure that she is pregnant or not
looking at the calf with the things
maybe less than three years did he lose
your calf is she is still walking
they'll ask if the baby is very close I
was talking earlier of some of their
animals that I think are careless
mothers and I mentioned the giraffe is
one of the animals I think done a very
good job
very good elephant is one of the big
five in Africa and I think Sydney is
trying to track another a big five in
South Africa I have got the Lions
hunting a water park at the moment here
anything can happen at any time I can
see that these Lions the water buck is
slowly approaching and that water park
is looking looking but so far the water
bag is not seeing anything and I don't
even know which pride is this but I can
see that these lions are very much
static and the water park is in the
middle of the bush now the universe are
starting to give some warning calls
which might even elect the water park at
the moment you can hear some squealers
are also starting to make noise so these
styles are slowly coming following the
water park I can see that look at that
look at that look at that look at that
look at that look at that you can see
the lines coming there chasing chasing
chasing look at that they are chasing
what about now they are chasing a water
back antique they were too fast to
change that what about I don't think
they are going to be successful here
oh that what about managed to escape
they were too fast to go for that water
back so they were not patient enough
look now I have got them right in front
of me and the water but God disappeared
and not all of them managed to
participate on that hand think the right
winner decided to go fast
so they still have got the interest of
going further but I think the right
winger made a mistake because she
started running without communicating
with the left winger and the other ones
at the back so it was coordinated but I
think the coordinator failed to inform
the other members that now is the time
we can go so lions are the the piece
with hunters the piece with hunters it
means the hunt as a group and they
coordinate the work together they've got
different positions they locate each
other quite a certain responsibility
with the the killers in the middle when
these right wingers are cornering an
animal those are the ones who are
normally taking down a big animal
Linda ADEA means the water bug and that
was a great opportunity I thought they
were going to go to catch that because
it was a nice available cover it's just
that that one started to run very fast
somewhat amazed now they are cornering a
hippo let me pull forward now they want
to follow you here for now let's see if
they win here there might be another
hour they are giving up they know maybe
he put something else I can see this
hippo out of the water and one of them
is looking at the hippo and this is
happening right here in front of me you
will see the way I'm gonna stop now
on my left-hand side we are going to see
this lion behind the lion you will also
see the hippopotamus but now they are
not really going after that hippo they
are now lying down and one of them is
going very close to the heap of a even
the hip are looking at each other as a
distance is less than 8 meters look at
that and the other ones are not
interested to go joy in that word
you can see the hippopotamus is right on
the background there and the
hippopotamus I realized a lion is not in
front I can see what the hippopotamus is
also doing there it is moving the head
all the time
so don't get surprised as well here we
are not alone at the sighting they are
there some guests as well who are
enjoying the sighting so that lion
always very close to the a Papa Thomas
has got quite a lot of interest I think
it's a young male so the experience the
ones are lying down here who knows the
hippos is tough to take them down
so I can see that they are now very much
in Lex I don't even know how many these
loans are but it's quite a lot I can see
one two three four five six seven eight
I have counted eight at the moment there
might be more than eight you can see
that the one who was very close to the
hippo is coming back because he did not
get a lot of support so the hippopotamus
is not moving at all that one now as
living himself is just now defecating
right there next to the road this is
what the Lions do the most when they
wake up late afternoon they isolate
themselves for a while and they just go
and defecate to a short distance so we
are very lucky to find the lands active
by this time of the day Isabella eight
versus one they can be able to make that
hippo tired but maybe they can see that
is much what hippo and it's a
territorial male I can see that the
outer layers of the eyes is showing me
that duck the darker color of the outer
layer of the eyes tells that it's a male
a female is pink so the male's they can
be very much aggressive maybe that is
why they are now moving away from the
animals we are very lucky to see the
Lions much more active when the Sun is
beta four degrees Lions are conducting a
hunt lovely isn't it
Joshua when it comes to hunting you must
have to think about the following the
hippopotamus can run 36 km/h the layers
can run up to 80 km/h but the thing is
who is going to run fast when the
animals are stalking a prey remember
they make sure that the concealment is
right
they hide and this surprise they launch
a surprise even if an animal has good
high speed but if surprised if a launch
has been surprised then the time you
realize this coming is too late that is
how these animals are catching their
prey
so you can see now the lying down again
some of them must have him to lie down
flat again so the water bug was much
more idea to take down than the
hippopotamus
so now let's cross over to the Maasai
Mara
where Steve has got a lovely egg welcome
back thanks Sydney I hope your your
Lions happen to come across something to
snack on in wild hippos or a very
interesting thing for Lions snack on is
you'll probably see tomorrow afternoon
look what we found alone out in the bush
no nests no adults a single egg ostrich
egg look at the size of it 24 eggs
apparently in there somewhere around
that and that's rotten completely rotten
I can even smell it on my hands now
Elvis is the range of the back who
collected it and he's pulling a very
very sour face behind me and oh my word
so he was wondering am I going to fry it
are we gonna cook it but it's definitely
rotten you can smell it it's permeating
through the shell but isn't that an
incredible sized egg for ostriches and
they will lay a number of those on and
they're on a nest out in the open and
the adults will incubate them at
different times but they'll first lay
all of them and one at a time because it
takes a good half a day sometimes 24
hours to develop an egg and they'll move
away and then come back again lay
another one move away and then they will
sits on the nest for a one period once
all the eggs are there so that all the
chicks hatch at the same time called
synchronistic hatching said all the
chicks will hatch and due to the size of
this egg there's an enormous amount of
yolk and that's food to assist in the
chicks to get much bigger than they
would if they're in a nest in a tree or
something like that so that is a term
called precocial meaning
pre-developed they come out and they're
pretty much ready to follow mum around
they're just these little Tony bundles
of of down feather and they can follow
mum around and pick and pick and pick Oh
James is now laughing at me well does
not smell nice I'm gonna put it back on
the ground next to the road where it
belongs and I don't even think a honey
badger would be interested in the sky
pass one of us have now got very smelly
hands and well folks I've been trying to
woof search the literature the
literature that's spelt with G double og
OE and my books for how much a buffalo
can eat in the day and I can't find it
anyway
lots of information telling you what a
Buffalo's deities but and conquering
with me about 35 odd litres some say 45
litres they can drink in a matter of
minutes
sometimes twice a day or they'll drink
depending on the temperatures but no
where can I find how much they're
physically canny today the reality
though is that they are a bulk feed up
so they do feed on a lot of food but if
you go through a rumination stage you
feed on a lot less then you would if
your hand get fermenter so a zebra has
got twice the amounts of food going
through than an animal of its equivalent
size that is a ruminant and that is just
a guy who sits in the gut for half the
time so ruminants they can feed on a
fair amounts of food but it goes through
slowly so that in higher-quality food
zebra elephants black and white runner
warthog well they can just feed on bulk
quickly quickly going through and the
gut retention time is very low it's all
sort of fermentation that happens sort
of in the back of the guts
that's what causes them to be very very
farty very flatulate big Fletch laters
of the bush that is where as a buffalo
when the conditions or the vegetation
gets quite poor there's still feed on
the same amount but they don't get as
much quality out of a lower quality
vegetation so that's one of the benefits
of being a ruminants
or negatives of being a ruminant versus
our non-ruminant or hung out from answer
is that when the quality of the
vegetation diminishes as we've seen in
Juma madrasahs in the Buffalo last year
everyone remembers I wasn't there but I
saw some footage and there's carcasses
all over the place the Buffalo do very
badly or lots of room owners do very
badly when the conditions are very poor
we're seeing it now with Indiana and
Juma I'm not sure if that's changed in
the last couple of weeks
Retin zebras warthogs I just keep going
on keep doing their thing they're gonna
feed more but they get better they get
more out of the quantity that they're
feed on if that makes any sense
that's all through fermentation in the
gut Oh
so I hope that clears a little sheds a
little bit of light but up
I'm not finished I know there is a book
out there my friends got one on graders
and it gives you all of this information
I know that information is there if if
anyone has that information on them
right now please feel free to pop it in
on a on a Twitter or on it with a
message or on the YouTube chat stream
let us know how much Oh James I don't
know what I've done here but we have
picked a road that has been disused for
some time can you maybe say that
question again for me please mo while I
navigate this very treacherous path
there's a road by the way it's just
disused
James it's a very good question I mean
ostrich chicks survival has really got
to do with a predation in an area I
think you know you can get anywhere from
sort of ten to fifteen sort of eggs
being laid all those chicks will hatch
or not all of them a lot of them will
get stolen their prized I mean that egg
there is ideal every spotted something
that egg is an ideal food source for
plenty of animals Archer mongooses and
badgers even I ena jackal will go for it
even baboons are supposed in humans will
go for the eggs and how many survivor
well the pit ostriches are very good
add-on are very good are sort of parents
sorry I'm being pointed out something in
the distance
we might have something of interest I've
got some topi are we scared see if I can
answer your question bitter so I suppose
they were quite a high success rate in
areas of low predation but unfortunately
aren't on these sort of plans there are
so many predators that ostrich ostriches
I don't know the exact number but
they've probably got a very low survival
rate we don't see too many ostriches
around and they are able to breed quite
readily which means they're able to have
a number of chicks at the same time and
while I haven't seen any chicks since
I've been here so there's a good chance
that a lot of them are now caught and
eaten not only to to to ground or
terrestrial predators but also to aerial
predators Isabella there are extremely
nutritious and I've heard of people
having ostrich omelettes can you imagine
the size of that woof Oh smell is
following us around so James I'm sorry I
don't have an exact number food on the
success of ostriches
li I had my salads yes I did and our
eggs for desserts I could have saved
some for breakfast but unfortunately I
don't know about you many of you ever
tried to eat a rotten egg
I made the mistake once of of making an
omelets of 13 the eggs into the pan and
then mixing it well scrambled egg it was
very big mistake
you've got to crack them each into a cup
and then throw them in otherwise you can
really spoil whatever it is that you're
trying to eat I've done that once before
I'll never do it again learn my mistake
and it takes one rotten egg to spoil the
batch but you are James I'm sorry I
haven't seen any juvenile ostriches as
I've been here a few females and a few
males together but none of that sort of
small diminutive kind that is I haven't
seen them so ice I suspect up here the
survival is quite low but in sort of the
more arid areas where you've generally
got the less predators per sort of
hectare I'm sure the survival increases
quite a lot
Oh smell that that's a dead animal yes
it is there's a carcass over here
there's nothing quite like the smell of
a rotten dead animal to take your mind
off your stinky hands that smelt of
ostrich rotten egg lovely smell today
and those smells I hear in the dark
disgust oh yes oh yes very exciting well
I know if the Lions were around and the
wind picked up and they smelled that
they'd probably get quite excited but it
seems as if Sydney's Lions have decided
to take a nap so you can see that the
boomers are starting to come together
now they are resting not very far away
from the hippopotamus they are just
lying down at a distance of about 20 25
meters away from the hippopotamus so
they are coming together so far I have
counted nine so the the ninety one I can
say it is far behind maybe it's gonna
come this side much more closer so now
they are doing what the known for
sleeping long hours during the day so
that is the ninth one so these critters
are making quite a lot of noise
vocalizing against that one so this we
decide by all means to inform the
waterboxx earlier on it's just that the
water buck was not seeing what was
happening so this feels cold cold cold
and the water bar kept coming kept
coming until these legs started talking
and getting closer and last one decided
to go fair the first one decided to go
first without informing the others so
these Lions when they're hunting they
coordinated make use of their tails and
the tip of the ears you see the es
moving every time and also the tails so
we didn't we didn't see too much
communication amongst that group
so maybe when joy the hippopotamus is
just standing there and he might have
been there maybe since this afternoon or
since this morning they can spend much
time standing like that this is not very
rare
it's what the hippos do when they are
away from the water holes sometimes you
can see the hippopotamus very long
distances such as 16 kilometers away
from the territorial water holes and
then they come back to the water holes
afterwards he's not very far away from
the water hole I can estimate that it
might be about 600 700 meters away from
the water hole so he's not very far you
can hear the others falling from the
water hole
m'kay the hippo is trying to be
invisible so it means this before Thomas
got stuck here because of the Lions
maybe why because the eve of Oh Thomas
it has been very hot and 34 degrees for
him to stand there all day long is very
bad to the skin hippopotamus they do
secrete some kind of fluid in order to
try and fight the sunburn but they must
have to be going in and out of the water
hole maybe this is the main cause of him
stuck in there without going to the
water hole so but then we just went to
wait here and see what's going to happen
the time he's moving back to the water
hole we might see some action between
him and their lions
Michelle
the possibilities are very much high we
are talking about an adult hippo so this
e PO is huge I can promise you this
learns at 10 they are nine and trying
that hippo is a big mission a Papa
traumas can be very dangerous
he can ingest some of these lions years
there is records where lions do take
hippos but it's not an easy exercise
Gavi I think for nine lions the
hippopotamus is is enough compared to
the size of the water buck they lost
Elia
they just got to eat this very thick
skin so that hippopotamus knows very
well what is happening
he saw the Lions anyway easy can still
see the Lions and is not worried about
them at all so you can see the young
male is a day at the moment also resting
I think I saw another young male as well
I cannot see where it is when the Lions
are starting to grow the main normally
is when they order than two years so the
main is showing you that they are
getting there they're about to mature
adjust that's gonna take them one or two
years again in order to be fully mature
word so that men contribute a lot when
it comes to the absorption of the Sun
it's like a scarf it helps them when
it's cold and it brings quite a lot of
heat when is hot but it does say for
many other purposes such as the
protection of the net when they are
challenging each other for
territoriality
ticktick the hippopotamus they can be
very much strong sorry for that
hippopotamus are very much strong
animals and if you check within the
whole animal kingdom
hippopotamus are the first group with a
very huge record of killing people every
year when talking about the mammals
within the animal kingdom but the animal
killing people alert every amongst the
whole animal kingdom is the mosquito so
but when talking about mammals mammals
are those animals with heads
they've got mammary gland they are
endemic they regulate their own body
temperature and they've got a
well-developed brain so when talking
about those ones hippopotamus is the
first one but when talking about
everything including insects etc is just
a class insects force under kingdom
Animalia so the animals
I can see that this evil were Thomas is
not even moving at all is just standing
there
so this is what the hippos are doing as
well when they go to the buffers hook
them they get there and then the wait
because there's no water now we'll see
them out of the water you're out of the
dry damn so now let's cross over back to
the Masai Mara and see what Steve is
having at the moment thanks Elvis
spotted two servo we've just moved in
here to see if we can see them they are
completely invisible how he saw them I
mean seeing an ostrich egg from the road
is easy but to see serval somewhere here
in front of us I can't see them can you
still see them they're here somewhere
probably quite shy they probably just
ducked down just duck down away from us
I remember how camouflaged these animals
are they're disruptive camouflage or the
spots is able to make him blend into the
background
stealthy silent camouflaged hunter that
we could see a moment ago now is
invisible
I'm not sure either em and I think she
saw something spotted to the left of
that termite mound I don't see it they
just have to lie down and they'll
disappear I saw them from back there I
saw two one adult and a youngster moving
maybe in a moment they'll come out again
once they realize we're no threat it is
indeed eagle eyes Elvis Loren he is
incredible and he was pointing it out
again this way that way we're looking
with the camera binoculars and then we
eventually saw them moving incredible
that's what you call a search image and
you spend a lot of time doing something
you develop a pattern recognition you
develop something that you see through
bushes you see around things and certain
shapes materialize for you and well
there's several materialized for Elvis
and fast for just a brief moment and now
they are gone absolutely incredible
moving through this long grass in search
of whatever food there might have it as
possible that it's the adult female may
be moving one of her youngsters from one
den to another and not as relaxed as a
female we saw not so long ago that's in
a much more sort of vehicle rich area
many more people are chair probably with
the first vehicle that it's seen and the
protective mum I'm just gonna keep
scanning James sorry I'm very keen to
show you all the servo just goes to show
how many just goes to show how many
there probably are out in the African
wilderness and very hard to to see them
all the time but epaulet you want to
know how tall they're stand total length
is up to 120 centimeters and they can
stand about 60 centimeters at the
shoulder so talk to normal rulers and so
it's quite tall for a cat of this sort
of state
quite all but it's mainly their long
legs that provide that for them a really
long legs for a very small body they
don't have an enormous body but the long
legs abled them to stand quite tall and
be quite elevated in this long grass so
that they can see down and also it's
built to jump quite high in search of
any food they were that very nice
pounced they'll jump up and land on top
of prey and also by having the long legs
they're able to sort of look down into
the grass and also gives them a little
bit more of a Vantage higher up so that
they could actually move through that
little bit more stealth and I've
designed for being very fast just for
having a spring-loaded jump and well as
you can clearly see the camouflage works
extremely well well for those of you who
have never seen a server before I have
got my trusty book here to show you the
serval there it is on the right hand
side it's a very beautiful cat very
beautiful indeed and look how long those
legs up a very long legs being stretched
and I know the photo doesn't do it
justice but they've got a very short
stubby tail the tails actually cut off
there but there you go
here is a serval with their big ears and
that disruptive camouflage that assists
not only camouflaging them while hunting
but also when people are trying to find
them hidden in the long grass okay well
we're around the corner the Sun is
setting behind the mountain we can't
really get a good view but that's why we
work as a team because David gets you is
positioned in just at the right place
very well done Steve over full cutting
that cellar cut quite quite quite quite
a sighting I would say to see them and I
think either him or someone else had
seen a Saab or with some Cubs the other
day but here we are enjoying the sunset
and Bungay has told me this is not a
sunset
he's called the golden moment or the
golden light I do not know what that
means but we quietly here watching the
Sun going down in the mark triangle and
murder triangle being in Kenya are we
being in East Africa we always 12 hours
12 hours could you just along the
equator so our sunsets or sunrises do
not vary very much not for more than a
couple of minutes we have standard
sunsets and sunrises almost all round
area
boom boom gay what should you prefer
that's very beautiful in the anime take
you back to that sounds it boom game
would you like to take Lee in the box
with that for couple of seconds Linda
says how beautiful Thank You Linda
that's a great comment and wenge is so
kind
he has taken us back to that stance it
for you Linda and look at all those
colors I don't know what or how I gonna
describe him but it just gorgeous
amazing wonderful colors Bungay would
you like more sunsets or sunrises all
right I give Bunge a question in saying
what can you see or what do you think
but you know he inclined to say he loves
his sunsets and Linda I agree with you
that is amazing the clouds coming down
their son is disappearing in the western
and maybe a mere alarm will ask all the
viewers what you think and they told me
maybe in one word twit what about that
sunset to the western horizon
just one word you can treat as usual
hashtag Safari live and tell me what you
think of that sunsets because to me is
out of this world out of this world at
Truman Watts thank you as soon as
dancers start coming in let me know I
said he's out of this world that's not
correct because that is more than one
watt and what I'm requesting is one watt
and I think things are going very well
as much as I'm enjoying enjoying the
sunset here giraffe I mean certainly got
some exciting moments look at that I
have got a giraffe approaching a lion
pride at the moment two giraffes are
coming and I'm not too sure if these
giraffes have seen the Lions but I can
see that the giraffe is now moving away
to that nearest big tree and you can see
you can see that the giraffe is moving
away so it looks like the giraffe
spotted the Lions so the Lions they did
not see these giraffes coming until they
saw them when they were too close and
the giraffes are trying to avoid they're
just passing by maybe 30 meters away
from the Lions and the Lions are looking
at the giraffes at the moment and then
they're going just behind the
hippopotamus who is now sleeping so
they've got a very nice available cover
the giraffes there they are watching the
Lions from that angle
so these giraffes are avoiding these
lions at the moment and lions are now
starting to wake up their heads here to
check what's happening maybe we might
also see something very interesting here
just like what we saw what happened to
the water back you can see that many
predators are near the water holes
things do happen look another giraffe is
trying to avoid look now but one lion
interested yesterday is moving facing
one of the
so look at that you can see another one
is starting now to wake up there is a
gap between the two giraffes and the gap
might be 50 meters giraffes are 50
meters apart from each other
now that other one is following the
first one at the moment and between the
Lions and the giraffe they say Ipoh
which is now a stumbling block as well
so I can see that the giraffes might
come to the open space at any time but
not exactly where the Lions are so the
squirrel is not stopping informing these
animals about this Lions here so it
looks like this giraffes are on their
way to the cheetah cheetah them or to
the nearest waterhole Deborah I don't
think the giraffes will be able to run
now but the problem is the one who is
moving now the lion you can see the
giraffe spotted that lion is a young
male the hippo is standing up as well
now because you can see the line is
moving so that lion looking at the size
of the mane is telling me to the young
not well experienced and is trying to
take over the responsibilities which are
for the females normally lions are
omitted when this kind of hands are
taking place and that is what is maybe
chasing the giraffes because the well
experienced females who are responsible
of stalking and taking down an animal
and they are here now and that young
male wants to interfere and the giraffe
spotted him I can even see I was
standing that he doesn't know how to
approach professionally
a James I didn't copy the question
nicely if you can repeat that
so now you can see that the hippo is
standing so when I'm looking at this
Lions
looking at the stomach's the only two
lions I can easily see the stomach is
the two-man gain emails the two-man get
emails is what I'm going to show you now
these are the ones I can tell the
stomachs are not full but I know when
these animals when this pride is good
meal
the oklahoma's they are prioritized and
these ones they come last mostly so when
looking at the goomahs as well
the stomachs are not that full so this
Lions they are looking hungry look at
that one standing now as well you can
see that the stomach is not that big so
it looks like the UN Coahoma males are
starting to recover from mange it's not
as bad as a few weeks ago look at that
so now that is the lion I hope that
lioness is one of the experienced
females you can see she stood up from
here where the other females are so if
that one is now looking at the giraffes
a transistor strategizing the approach
direction but those giraffes I can see
they're very worried we are at the back
now still looking at these Lions
so they're now moving away you can see
the one leading in front is now avoiding
maybe the lands might try to follow them
we will see our beard one of my previous
guests these lions are beard you know
these new Papa Thomas our beard is a
fully grown hippo so that is the hippo
who can be able to defend himself that
one it can be very dangerous I can
promise you looking at that mouse
structure I can see his big and much one
we might see a a real interesting action
here maybe these lands are waiting for
the hippo to come how to the open space
so that is where the hippo is feeling
safe at the moment he doesn't want to
move is just lying down at the same spot
and standing at the same spot
so you can see now it looks like the
interest from one of the female who
stood there last is gone because the
giraffes are now very far I can see now
they are maybe at about 300 meters away
from the Lions so the chances of any
action now they are very much slim so we
are still going to sit here and see what
is going to happen because when we are
sitting here the chances are very high
to see something animals are all
approaching from this very same
direction animals are coming to these
lives the Lions are just like down
animals are just presenting themselves
we are at the right spot at the moment
so now the Sun here in South Africa is
still high up a little bit but by the
Maasai Mara David is chasing the Sun
before it get disappeared
very good and I'm sure you all know we
are one hour ahead of South Africa and
that's why the Sun Also here will set
one hour ahead of South Africa and so
exciting to have giraffes and lions in
Sydney
well I moved on a little bit and of
course the Sun kept going down and have
a different ballgame now on the sky and
I'm sure you're all ready with the
answers even a buddy might have sent one
word for the sunset we had before with
all those clouds coming down and still
it has not gone home yet highly very
good magic is a great word magic hey do
you say very good good and yeah I
requested one word tweet on hashtag
Safari live on how that sounds it was
and still now I think it is still
beautiful good-looking
so the moment you're gonna use Haley's
word magic and the different colors like
that word you had before or the
intensity has changed and you can see
the tree line there Renee you say
heavenly just like heaven thank you very
much heavenly is an equally beautiful
word so we got heavenly we got magic
keep sending them and I was talking with
a tree line on the horizon there and I
would guess most of those trees are what
we call the Torchwood trees and a very
iconic of the Mara triangle dark clouds
they're building not that you'd have any
rain but I'll not be surprised maybe
later on tonight one day you think it
might rain showing the blind that's a
good one blind magic and heavenly we got
three very tough ones thank you and keep
bringing them on and we'll keep moving
and my plants as head area
if it would be possible I'd be happy to
see the waffles how does it look boom
get on your left can I come over the car
it's good to go alright
boom gaze my camera operator I know
sometimes he works as my co-driver
yes he's his side mirror it's pretty
cool okay
I'll put in my junkie now that's got a
bit cool
it will help me just not get cold it's
at one point if the cow is Wharton
doesn't come in to us
okay going now to the waffles and
hopefully I haven't seen them for about
a week and hopefully they're still the
same place
Linda thank you great comments and
hopefully I will get them have not been
there as I said for couple days so Linda
don't go away stay tuned and hopefully
we'll get the commander-in-chief of the
Northland waffles herself and maybe with
hard grounder to soup who knows
Apollo's good evening in Pallas I've
seen sometimes hyenas going for impalas
we got a hard here I should collect a
bleeding-heart
females and with one male as usual which
is the typical structure of impalas
Peter flight has enjoying the sunset
still have what moon gate told me it's
not a sunset but the golden light and
I'll be calling it the golden light and
not sunset anymore true soon you saying
you love my jacket thank you very much
I've had this jacket for a long time and
I got it in a town called Arusha in
Tanzania so thank you very much and
hopefully you'll get some screenshots of
my jacket any time you see it you think
of Africa that's the male that is in
charge of all the females here and he'll
always make sure they stay very close to
him and that guarantees he's able to
meet with all of them and impalas being
mixed feeders energy still be eating
both leaves or twigs grows at the same
time and you can see all of them feeling
differently
all these lovely animals to see and
doing very well with all the rains or
the short rains going on you can see
some of the grass the children special
is pretty green yaku you say you love
those tails and will be surprised yacon
if they happen to run and they leave the
tail up it's all white and they use that
still no of the white bit of it a
follow-me sign you see some of them are
just wanna just keep looking jerker and
see once they wag those tails
you can see the white part and truly
also the block yeah you see that's what
I was talking about that's exactly what
they do when they run but also the three
black stripes or so they use them during
the day us follow me sign should they
end up in some thickets or in grass and
they're running or they're just walking
basically and you cannot see your
colleague you just follow those three
black stripes or three black lines on
their bombs they're the male always
being very busy putting the females in
one particular area and they don't last
very long holding the harem because of
course it's very tiring looking at what
maybe 30 females here it's a lot of work
move that tree go backwards and making
sure no other male comes in his
territory and of course in the process
of you know working so hard to do that
they weigh out very quickly and then
should another male come and try him out
he very easily loses the battle to an
email
south african i think was a very defiant
breeding season for impalas and either
this month or early December
they should be dropping down the alums
City concentrate on that short yummy
green grass in order dry grass and
likewise with elephants alia eating
fantastic not once the world the other
day we saw some lions here in the Mara
bringing down an Impala
so these lions are still here very much
relaxed and the hippopotamus is just
laying down and standing lying and
standing and it looks like these lions
are waiting for the movement of that
hippopotamus to come out from that thick
bushes I can see that one of them is
aiming at that hippopotamus is just
looking at what the hippo is thinking
about to do every time the hippo is
moving the lions concentrate you can see
that is the one which is monitoring the
situation at the moment the rest of the
Lions are all lying down flat so you can
see that she is being fascinated by that
hippopotamus
please the Alliance the they do try to
take down this hippopotamus and apart
from the lions other predators were not
as large as the Lions such as the
Highness has been spotted as well trying
to take down the hippopotamus it even
happened by the Maasai Mara some time
ago when a group of hyenas was trying to
take down a hippopotamus by the dam so
Papa Tamas they do experience predation
by this kind of animals yes they do have
very thick skin but lions when they are
too hungry they do try their luck and
they don't always win but they do try
their luck but now at this stage when
the bush is so very dry grasses don't
have lot of nutrients a lot of animals
different species they are not in a very
good condition which might also
contribute to us this shortage of
strength when these animals are trying
to defend themselves against these very
big predators
so only the Predators by this time of
the year they look healthy because it's
when a lot of animals are dying from
shortage of food and they are eating so
the Predators is the one that don't
normally lose weight during the dry
season is when predators are gaining
quite a lot of weight because it's easy
for them to get food
James at the moment from whenever
arrived here the hippo has never never
shown any sign of interest look at that
you see that lion wants to try the hippo
from the back look at the day boy is
lying down facing the western side and
the liar
pushing the hippo from behind we might
see some interaction there so the this
lie this hippopotamus have not yet shown
us any level of aggression since our
arrival maybe now that the lion is
moving much more towards the
hippopotamus we might see something look
at that you can see the lion is getting
closer and closer now look at that yeah
we can we can maybe share this sighting
with the other way was from other social
networks
a very very good afternoon and welcome
to the beginning of this special
broadcast my name is Sydney former
anomie cozy and I'm having one of the
best sightings at the moment I have got
look at that now with something nearly
happened you can see that that Lyon
nearly got charged by the hippopotamus
the hippo was trying to come and he was
so fast to react this is happening not
very far away from the chitwa chitwa we
are just by the western side of the
greater Kruger National Park in South
Africa so the lion we are seeing there
is quite a very big size difference look
at the hippo in the lion the lion looks
very tiny the lioness we are seeing now
is part of the uma pride which is the
pride lying down right in front of me so
the thing is the other ones are sleeping
flat only that one felt interested to go
and try the hippopotamus at the moment
so you can see that the hippopotamus
turned and it's looking at the lion so
you can see now that the lion gave up
praise coming back and if we can wait
here we might see something happening
later on because this is not the first
try they tried the hippopotamus first
during my arrival and this is the second
try you can see now is back fo grooming
maybe is just now talking about lack of
support when she went for a try Michael
from Denmark is so fascinated by what
the lion is trying to do trying such a
very big and dangerous animal you can
see now is visiting the second one maybe
it's just complaining that guys why are
you not supporting me you know we are
working as a team but I went there it
didn't follow me why maybe that is what
is asking now
so I'm just waiting here to see if
something is going to happen but from
what I'm seeing I think the the try is
over they might try again and thank you
very very much for all your questions
and commands indeed this has been a
fabulous sighting
welcome back from such a very
interesting action between the
hippopotamus and the lion
I think the is the voice of the squirrel
is dying now listen to that this critter
has been calling for the whole one hour
and now the voice I can hear that is
starting to go down
look at that squirrel it's right here by
this branch on this tree he has been on
the other side and it's two of them you
see the one day and there's another one
in the middle branch shaking the tail
the one who's calling at the moment so
these are the spirits who are trying by
all means and tell everybody go away
they are right here don't come this side
so is what they're doing at the moment
so they the giraffes were also told and
I'm sure when the giraffes or the Lions
they were saying why did I tell you I
told you from well us too far don't come
this side and then you came closer you
see this is what is happening the
dangerous alliance the right here lying
down at the moment
so now let's cross over back to the
Maasai Mara and hear what is happening
shortly after the sunset
apologies for the inconvenience due to
lack of signal we are back again at the
lion sighting and I don't think is is
best to be with these Lions because they
are on a mission they are lying down
here and what they are lying down they
can hear what's happening every movement
taken by the hippo they are waking up
they're checking so it looks like these
Lions they are deliberately lying down
here for the hippo to take any action to
come to the open space so that they can
launch an attack
so you can see that mail now is flat
all of them are flat at the moment so
none of them is monitoring the hippo
anymore but I know their hearing ability
is excellent and their eyesight is
excellent these lions can still see they
are managing the hippopotamus while they
are sleeping so you can see the
manganese ions here if so now Steve is
back and we can quickly go back to him
and see what he wanted to show us
previously sorry about the technical
issues folks are not quite sure what
happened there but our hairier stalks
are slowly trying to make get a nice
sort of comfortable position in the
branches of this very tall and spiny
tree one of the reasons they do that is
because they are servile on the ground
they are jackal they are all sorts of
nocturnal predators that might snack on
them the reason why and the ostriches
don't do so well is of all the predators
that I have the ability to fly up into
the tree and there I can just jumping
back to some ostrich facts there's only
about 33% of all ostrich eggs laid I
actually incubated which is a very low
number to be for you to be fair and
there's about 0.9 percent of the chicks
per nest actually are you reach
adulthood so that is a very very low
number and a lot of it to do with
predation and a lot of the reasons why
even birds that don't have the very
necessary perching ability like these
stalks well will go up into the tree
because well you don't want to fall
victim to something on the ground that
even though marabou storks are quite
vile and smelly creatures and you feed a
lot of carrion an opportunistic predator
will snack on them good well there was a
question asked earlier and I managed to
phone a friend and James Henry
myself was able to give me some
information on how much a buffalo here
comes a jackal James I was just talking
about a predator on the floor and
there's a jackal just run across the
road in front of us if it comes out in
the open we might be able to spot him
we're going to go into IR now folks as
the light you saw David sunset is
setting so we are going to go into the
IR spectrum a map and if you don't mind
and so James Henry was kind enough to
send me back some information and a
buffalo in captivity will feed in about
15 kilograms of hay in one day so it's
about 30 odd pounds of hay but obviously
hay is generally quite nutritious so out
here in the wild so you could probably
estimate that a buffalo feeds on maybe
20 20 I've sum up just over 40 pounds of
food per day and in the winter months
probably even more due to the lack of
nutrients in while Dan and Zuma they'd
have to feed on some more brows and
really have to scrounge out to the
landscape to get the necessary food so
that's a decent amount of food they have
to feed on every single day to keep them
going so there we go
that's to answer Evander's herbiness
areas question from earlier I wasn't
able to find these answers anyway but I
phoned a friend and I have come up with
the answers thank you James if anything
these stocks would eat your baby to be
honest I love the story of stalks
delivering babies it is always quite one
of those nice sort of children's stories
isn't it no no these stalks and I do not
deliver babies I'm still I actually need
to read up on exactly where that story
came from because it really is one of
those ones that from us in the Western
world we really do remember don't we
storks and babies but the marabou stalk
my no means are they the deliverers of
babies they walk through the landscape
feeding on baby birds that fall out of
nests
I found them many times that queerly
abreast breeding sites where babies are
falling out any baby bird that falls out
of a nest while a marabou stork will
snack on them
they all feed on carrion quite readily
and they're often found and associated
sadly enough with human waste sites so
they do like to move into areas where
human waste sites accumulate and
obviously those areas attract rodents
and all sorts of other nasties okay
trying to find a nice comfortable spot
that's tricky they haven't picked in my
opinion the nicest tree in the world oh
that's my spot
Joey I'm not 100% sure if they eat trash
but they'll eat the waste products and
maybe organic material that's there and
and the insects and the rodents that are
associated with the dump site that is
developed but I don't think they're
necessarily eat rubbish but the organic
material that is so often thrown away
these days I firmly believe that
everybody should be responsible for
recycling their waste and then also
dealing with all of the organic waste
that they're generate and it can be
easily done with worm farms with compost
piles black soldier flies we can all
deal with our own waste but too often
they are thrown away with the rest of
the rubbish and then where do we put it
mmm humanity has a very interesting
species obviously birds like this some
seagulls as well they all just adapt
adapt to live in those areas many
seagulls down in the coastal areas are
attracted to waste sites and sewage
works because of the effluent not
necessarily the effluent itself but the
productivity that that effluent provides
and they've evolved and adapted I mean
down in Cape Town one of the best
birding sites is at a sewage works
really really nice place to go and see
birds but I must warn you if you develop
gag reflex for certain things I would
not go there because well that's a good
chance that you're going to gag but a
wonderful place to see many many birds
and living in aquatic systems sewage
areas interesting isn't it mmm anyway
we're going to move on
and carry on down this road
see if we can eventually maybe spot a
lion in the long grass that Jacqueline
for she stayed a little bit low but
maybe not as low in fact Sydney's lions
after you can see that the two main
Guinea males are now laying down right
at the back here and they look much
better than previous because I can see
that now I can see quite a lot of ash
developing there so these are the
victims of mange mange it is a parasitic
disease mange is caused by one of the
parasites and when the animal is bitten
certain parts of the body got affected
negatively such as the elbows and the
ears sometimes it can spread around the
body is quite a very contagious disease
and animals can look very bad it's
associated with itching you see them
scratching against the poles and
scratching against the ground and also
loss of hesse so they lose quite a lot
of hands when they've got that you can
see that one day on a stomach that they
still some gray areas showing that it
was negatively affected also the elbows
you can see right there but I think this
is way much better than a few weeks ago
so if the other animals contact the the
blood if the contact blood with this one
the chances of also picking up mange are
very much high from getting it from the
parasite the upper side bites but they
can also get it from the close contact
so they are still sleeping at the moment
and the hippopotamus is just now on the
other side standing oh look at how the
hippopotamus is breathing is breathing
with a nose against the floor and you
can see the dust - and it's breathing
they look at that you can see the dust
coming out there look at that see
there's the dust day as if there is a
valve on the ground
oh this even all speakers right there
where the dust is coming from look at
that you can see that is the dust from
the breadth of this hippopotamus this is
interesting so he must be tired of
standing there that's why now yeah a
Michelle that was a WoW some something
very unusual so we don't see that very
often so you can see that now he's so
tired and he's trying to have they the
mouse against the ground yeah he's still
pretty much relaxed today and maybe I
cannot say is that earlier he's relaxed
because it's not moving around but he is
worried about the lions it must be
worried in the moment he's relaxed
because it doesn't have any other option
so now let's go back to the Maasai Mara
where the successful bidder David is
having something interesting well this
morning I saw some secretary bolts on
top of a tree with the sunset and then
like I'm ending my day with a different
band or rather in service in the morning
on a sunset now with count cranes and
not two but three the Sun the signature
bunch were two this morning with the
sunrise and now the sunset I don't have
two but three crowned cranes after
having spent in the better part of the
day feeding it's time to drag your feet
or come to their nest don't fly don't go
anywhere
look at that wingspan huge wingspan we
got and yeah I'm in the final control
says what's there not flying away what
they're doing is true York I love that
him they're doing tree yoga I love that
and you can see the balance on that
particular on that one small branch but
to me schwa exactly what she's trying to
do you look at how they're bending
that's exactly yoga I agree with um
that's exactly how yoga is done and then
[Music]
and it'll be surprised you know that
they're just stretching their mass was
they're having we need to have
insect-like the whole day the background
you can hear hyenas blue this is the
national bad of a country west of Kenya
could Uganda you may not see the colors
pre well because now we are in infrared
and that's why she appears black and
white and true that's you where she's
doing and then up facing the other way
stretching muscles from one set of a
shadow of the shoulder in generally
going to z-- the very monogamous but
once in a while you might give them
three and I think one of them could be a
youngster and I'm thinks while she's
doing a better job than ha and we should
just compare because I think we have a
large plant from the animals as human
beings we have always seen when lions
wake up from you know laying down how
this stretch their forelegs and this
stretch the spinal cords I think we have
everything to learn every day so many
countries in the world have national
bird so they said this is the National
bad for Uganda we have looked at the
American bald eagle in Kenya we have the
lilac breasted roller and we just see it
this lot what happens when you use
infrared it'll make sure you do not
influence the unmowed be betta bad by
shining in artificial light because if
they have an S there would be definitely
interfering with their behavior we need
just to enjoy the darkness
well vain duck doesn't mean we don't see
nice stuff and I think Steve might have
spotted something for himself yes we do
we've managed to finally find you a
servo I know the lights not great folks
we are in infrared as said before but
look at the size of those years and well
look at the eyes how they're shining
servers are able to be nocturnal as well
as dial-up and well there's nothing no
better camouflage than a termite mound
oh how disappointing we had it was
moving through the long grass almost
like a jackal and then I was like what
is that once again Elvis told me what it
was and it was indeed a serval cat the
beautiful spots beautiful coloration
enormous is that is the sort of way you
see Souls normally and you see them and
then they're gone that servo catch we
had a week or so ago with the kittens
that is just not normal to see them so
relaxed and to be able to follow them
for a long time is absolutely fantastic
and well here we had a brief view and
that's all you get in this evening but
I'll take that that was so awesome
well done
that just did Tom
moving through looking for any of the
birds that are trying to are there
here's James
oh he's God that's too far
proud kept mama those eyes are
incredible aren't they as he right
through us
wish I could have eyes like that you
notice our forward-facing they are
characteristic position of a of a hunter
of the predator eyes facing forward
obviously those animals that are
defending themselves against predators
have got eyes on the side of the head a
nice little trait to look for at an
animal when you're thinking what are
they are their prey or their predator
helps with the binocular vision the
focus point of direction
and the beautiful spots help it to just
blend in melt in with his environments
and can imagine how many servers we
drive past on a regular basis they meant
well but serval is moving on the forage
on the hunt for something to eat him
well hopefully David in his line or
sorry Sydney in his lines would be up to
something soon I am so jealous about
this several sightings because I haven't
seen this ever for quite a long time now
but one day I'm gonna go to the Masai
Mara and see those servers Here I am
still willing to whom us who are still
resting at the moment nothing is
happening they just raised resting
waiting for the action from the
hippopotamus once the evil start moving
we might see some actions taking place
here as we saw the two attempts area so
if you can check here where these
females are they are right lying down on
a pathway and other ones are also on a
pathway so the possibilities of other
species as well coming down to the
waterhole make use of the very same
pathways they are very high as we saw
the giraffes trying to come down make
use of the very same pathways so because
they are used to walk on this same
pathway chances of this are the
different species to come past year they
are very high they might be lucky and
get an easy meal
a crease the e Papa Thomas can go out of
the water holes for a day I have seen a
hippopotamus far away from the water or
before unfortunately they did not charge
us but I was on a guided walk and this
hippo was just hiding by one of the
thick bushes hippopotamus during the day
when it's hot if they get trapped by the
Sun they can be able to find a nice
protective spot and hide there and carry
on when the Sun comes down late in the
evenings these animals now at night they
can go for more than sixteen to thirty
are at 80 kilometers from the water
holes so if you can check around the
water holes where we are it is looking
very over grazed the these animals are
pressurizing these grasses in this area
all the time so that's why now they must
have to move long distances for them to
graze and get enough here by the water
hole is not possible so they must have
to travel long distances and even go
pass at the Juma Game Reserve to graze
in and also by other neighboring
properties they need quite a lot of
energy and they can also store some of
the food in the stomach in order to
survive much stronger if it is no enough
vegetation for them to eat they are not
ruminants the hindgut fermenters but
they've got that ability
oh yeah the giraffes are coming from
from this side we might see another
action David the girls they need to go
and get some food and the boys need to
go and patrol their territory so that
the girls can be safe inside so both of
them has got a huge responsibility one
is responsible to bring food another one
is responsible for the protection of the
whole pride so now those giraffes are
just coming to check if the Lions are
still in the area is the very same two
giraffes we saw earlier on trying to be
stopped by this Ryan Lions so but now I
can see they are trying to open a very
big gap and they don't want to come
closer anymore
so giraffe they've got a very a good
advantage because they are so very much
tall and yes the vocal call is not that
much noisy they don't make nice vocal
calls but the tip behind the ears that
bright color you are seeing when they're
spreading is what they're using for
communication that is how they can be
able to communicate and support each
other from a long distance so you can
see that there is an accommodation you
can see the roofs there that is Chitra
Chitra it is the accommodation which is
against the chitwa chitwa dam so
sometimes when we are following the
animals the lodge is appearing don't get
surprised
it is the lodge which is attached to the
dam where this heap of or traumas are
siding so this side nothing is happening
at the moment so we will wait here and
see what is going to happen but now
Steve is so generous about the young
Kuma's he is also looking for his own
lions let's see what is up - I wish I
had Lions looking for them indeed we've
covered a huge amounts of ground and
what we found is lots of Buffalo lots of
zebra
no liens following them so we're on this
road slowly gonna make our way back in
who knows what we could find it's cooled
down quite a lot so as time when Lions
get up and start moving so ever the
arena's have been secretin themselves
for the day we're hoping that we might
get them sooner we know that a lot of
the Lions like to move on to the road
easier to travel fast the distance or
cover distance a bit faster but they're
so interesting Oklahoma pride and on
[ __ ] Rogaine lawn Dalhousie which is
further south where the Birmingham boys
have been spending a lot of their time
the London lazy blog is discussing the
Oklahoma's being on their property of
late so how's that they've gone for a
little visit they've taken the kids to
visit dad for the weekend are there
quite quite funny so what we know about
lion dynamics and the movements of
prides is really just can everyday can
be thrown out of the window anything you
think you know about how lives move well
it can be written down you can see it
happen and it'll still surprise you we
see the lion prides moving around here
with almost no understanding of exactly
why they're doing what they're doing and
the only thing I can say is where the
food is that's primarily the way they're
moving
sorry about the bumps they just go
through bouts of calling just so that
they can okay you're over there today
I'm going to make sure that I'm over
here
they're just buffer themselves with with
calls so it's illuminating of their
direct conflict that should have
variably happen in an area of of prey
abundance but for the moment there's
plenty to go around and so interesting
than goomars have ranged so far Soph
a wonderfully one else got any thoughts
on that any thoughts on the Oklahoma's
taking their kids to meet dead fathers
it's about 20 20 minute drive if you
went straight I'm trying to think of the
distance it's quite far but Lyons you
know Lyons do what they want to do and
maybe they followed the Buffalo down and
they just got a bit disorientated it's
it's probably Chris you hope they bring
back to Birmingham boys well that should
be something wouldn't it we've all been
waiting in anticipation over the last
however many months for this Clash of
the Titans
sorry we've got some Buffalo in the road
ahead I don't want to blind him so The
Clash of the Titans of the Birmingham's
versus the Evo cause I think there
should be quite something to behold but
maybe maybe lions are as sentimental as
we are and they just took the kids to
visit dad or multiple dads for the
weekend you know it was Thanksgiving the
other day wasn't it yeah Birmingham's
were around in Juma when I started in
February January February the
birmingham's was still a fixture in Juma
and since I think it's about April
I might be a little bit off on the dates
about April or so it's when the
Birmingham just kind of vanished down
south and since then their vocals have
kind of moved in and so maybe just
before Christmas and around Thanksgiving
TV it would be something to see the
Battle of three versus four
battle-hardened veterans versus some
three upstarts and there'll be great so
around Christmas Thanksgiving what a
great time to take the kids to go and
see dad I think that's very sentimental
sorry that I'm anthropomorphizing our
liens but that is that is what happens
I'm sorry I'm I didn't quite get that
from deep
through this herd of buffalo
yeah
de it is indeed dad's time to babysit
but I don't know how long they stayed
for I just got a quick glance at it I
didn't actually read too much about it
but just the highlights that they were
down there and I do believe the
birmingham's are still in the area so
interesting what's going on is something
running over here not running it is a
nice job moving very quickly
nachos believe it or not have got
enormous eyes shining back in the
darkness so like we see the serval in
the darkness those eyes are very bright
the nachos got enormous eyes and they've
put a drink from from this rate of that
probably this swamp nacho because of
where we are but anyway David has
managed to sort out his infrared lights
and while he's looking at some elephants
in the darkness
well I've seen some Eddie's I have seen
some zippers and I'm getting very cool
close to the waffles territory I'm even
confused where I want to go now but
before I get to our for surgery
let me see Bungay can cut this zippers
it's just ahead of us about eleven
o'clock I'm spoiled by choice
look at that and how things look at
night in infrared and zebras are looking
at elephants but it gets dark visibility
becomes very poor for most of the
animals so the common zebra cause it
grants the zebras
and they can hear some pain as well as a
watch this is a brush let's find out
what Sydney's sighting looks like the
lion and the hippopotamus are looking at
each other look at the oh it's the popo
Thomas attend another lion trying his
luck again so you can see the lion is
coming back so you can see these Lions
they have got a mission they are waiting
for that people to come out of the open
space because at the moment they have
done their own assessment and they can
see that it won't be possible to
coordinate hunting and take that hippo
in the middle of that the bushes but now
you can see this is the third or fourth
one going and attempt to chase that
hippo they are trying to get that the
hippo out and their strategies are not
working
and the year we are talking about the
third largest land mammal it can weigh
up to one thousand six two thousand
seven hundred kilograms and that is too
big this is quite a very big animal
so these lions they've got to work hard
in order to take down these animals
because it's not just about the weight
is the weight and the equipment this
zipper has got the Zebras got very big
tooth which can grow up to 40 to 50
centimeters that is telling you any
mistake
one hip one one lion is gonna get badly
injured and some might even lose their
life here during the battle with the
Papa Thomas
I can see now one of them is starting to
groom now the Sun has gone down here in
South Africa I am not seeing the Sun
anymore I'm just seeing reflection by
the sky which is telling us that is a
time normal time for the lens to wake up
that's why grooming started the self
grooming is happening they might start
to greet each other and groom each other
and then take the hippo and try to take
the hippo down
Paulo they are waiting for two things to
happen they are waiting for that hippo
to come out of the open space and they
are also waiting for the darkness but
that is normal lions are much more
active between dawn and dusk so that is
when they are going to work but these
ones here are trying to get the hippo
out let's wait and see maybe these
people is is not going to come out also
during attack because if he comes out
here we are going to see something
interesting tonight
mrs. Lapwing let me try to judge the
distance now the dam is just about 500
600 meters away from where we are so
approximately 600 meters or less from
where we are and the distance between
hippos and the Lions is just about 20
meters 20 meters so you can see that
these distance 600 meters anything can
happen
a hippo cannot managed to get to they
were traveled before they caught him or
before they cornered him so the hippo is
not safe at the moment I think it's
quite a number of Lions 9 Lions can be
able to confuse the hippo and make him
tired I don't think he's gonna manage to
maintain the same speed for about 6 to
700 meters yeah they can run 10 to 6
kilometres per hour but this Lions where
they are they are right at least he
can't come out because they are right in
front of him if they are all trying to
go for an attack
and this Lions child of the universe
they've got to try harder I am strongly
agreeing with you and this is also gonna
help them in order to learn to take this
kind of dangerous animal I'm not too
sure if it's this this is the first time
they are trying the hippo they might
have tried the hippos many times before
because he posed on them they active at
the same time they active at night they
might have encountered each other a lot
during the night
so but this report let me just maybe
talk about this
this zipper has been disturbed this
zipper is standing and lying down and
I'm sure is getting tired
I don't think tonight when he's doing
his night activities we'll be able to be
very strong like before chances of this
alliance had to confuse or to take down
that he posed they are very high because
you can see he's tired how many times
have we seen him lying down since you
have been here and that is a sign that
it was tired
so now let's go back to Steve in
darkness we are in the darkness and just
when you think the migration has ended
we come across an enormous herd of all
the beasts that's crossing in front of
us with the zebra counterparts here they
go
we've already had a number of them
crossing ok traffic on the Sunday
afternoon is is horrendous here in the
Mara triangle these are scenes that we
saw a month ago and I haven't seen again
since the devel divest have returned
with the rains brought the green grasses
and whatever it might be climate change
or management practices down in that
Serengeti has caused them to come back
Gina they do have quite creepy eyes and
running like that - the actually
resemble you know running in the grass
except there are thousands of them I'm
not sure if you can quite hear them off
to our right hand side they're making
they were making a lot of noise
both calm down there was a plenty that
are crossing in front when we stopped
and when you find a herd of all the best
generally in the Mara in my experience
lions are not far behind can't help
themselves the noises and the smells of
these animals
okay well while we trying other weight
or get through this traffic jam let's go
see if David has yet arrived with the
North Klan
well I come finally I have arrived
arts the waffles then this is not worth
us but it's one member and I think she's
a female of the North clan a group of
hyenas is called a clan and where we are
now that's the exact barrel for what was
herself the numeration is one of the
senior fuels in the town that has been
taking care of office Cubs hyenas very
much vehicle and maybe office might have
left this under some instructions to
take care of the visitor comes ask me we
should have gone out patrolling the
boundaries so getting ourselves
something to eat or just scouting our
territory she seems to be curious of
something I don't know she is looking at
what are you looking at now I just want
to switch move the camera to about 12
o'clock one game from where we are
because they thought I saw some Cubs
I don't know how father I I'll go
whatever thinking is for us to switch
the camera to walk 12 o'clock and I'm
just trying to keep my voice is low my
voice does that we're not very loud at
that point I saw one coming from a
distance can see the eyes they are
twinkling Joshua that is waffle waffles
is not at the den at the moment
Cubs I'm sure they're within or inside
the barrel as you can see there that's
another hyena they're always very
difficult to tell a male from a female
hyenas very much Rico when the females
always in charge one of our leading
femurs he is called super with a
granddaughter of waffles and I think
super good to Cubs as well was also got
two cubs one called Olivia oh yeah
that's good Junaid
who are you looking at it's very quite
at the moment but you might not take
long before they start calling
from reducers you can hear some highness
Colleen
proud mama I'll just walk you first to
waffles and your question is how does
the can develop and grown happiness just
I'm sure you know the very complex all
the social relationship is very complex
for the hyenas and the very much Rioja
we have the females pulling the shots
just like the elephants I just learned
the other day that waffles fought how we
up to be top of this clan or to be the
commander in chief she didn't come from
a lineage where either the mother was a
high-ranking female but one of her
granddaughter's good soup has taken
about as one of the senior-most
outs in females and waffles got two of
her cubs and possibly one of that Cup
might take over from waffles so it's
always female
the lineage is very much female
dominated and the males do not have much
say when we come to managing or looking
at in the height hyenas complex system
so what was getting a bit old and I'm
sure I've had two cups if not soup maybe
who might stick over of course in the
sale area but she's a granddaughter of
waffles one of our comes might be the
one in charge or could be running or
managing this particular clan so in that
Barrow there I'm sure we got some Cubs
inside its might not take long before
they come out other you ask me the
hyenas are nocturnal and yes and yes
with piano depending on the size of the
clan depending on availability of food
you'll see Highness both day and night
it's very good Christian on what was
once a while you meet him out there
looking for food you know during the day
at night you'll come here she's here at
night will come like now she is not here
but I'm sure in that particular hole I
swear she leaves and you notice the bear
is not as big he's not meant for fully
grown highness he's just meant to hide
the Cubs in that way the hyenas mature
there would be other predators like
either lions or elephants don't reach
the it cubs the iris will always be
staying outside the burrows
don't we're gonna wait - waffles come
back
we have no idea where she is
Lee yes they're very complex and how
they live and how they divide their
roles is quite complex and Sydney as a
predator crossing somewhere so I've got
the pride is just about to cross now to
us the Torchwood
they might be here at any second look
the first one is leading and the rest
are just coming behind hair so it means
now they might execute their mission
much more decide they gave up when it
comes to the dangerous hippopotamus so
you can see the stomachs are empty so
this animals they've got to hunt for so
you can see that now they are starting
to cross the second one is going there
all on a convoy crossing at the same
place and this is beautiful look at that
this is an amazing sighting
I think the rest of the pride is far
behind as now I can see there's quite a
very big gap between this one cruising
now and the other ones at the back
I don't know if maybe they are incited
by something Linda just in time you can
see they are looking back there to check
if the other pride members are following
or not
so I'm just going to never eyes good
that they have left the hippopotamus
think the hippo is lucky because that
hippo have displayed her level of
aggression and they got nervous so now
that they have crossed I'm gonna have to
see if we can see these other ones which
are about to come and cross or else I
can see if we can still see those ones
we have already crossed
so those ones who are about to cross are
coming to cross at any time now I can
see they're right here led by a male and
a female following behind all is the
young man I can see while they're now so
look at that he can see this very
beautiful man there he's trying to check
where the other ones are at the moment
he can't see them but he knows they're
somewhere inside so look at the tassel
of the a tail so this is the only
species monks the failings the cat which
has got the tassel by the tail
don't get surprised I do have some other
vehicles also enjoying same sighting we
are having now so the tip of the tail
you start to notice that tassel only
about seven to eight month
yeah we are looking at the beginning of
a collision look now I can see the
manganese ions are also coming through a
cross over look at that you can see the
condition is not that very bad like
before there is a little bit of
improvement yeah there is quite a very
big improvement now they are recovering
so at the beginning this - they were so
looking bad and quite a lot of health
has been lost during that stage but now
everything is starting to recover oh the
other one lost the tip of the tail
doesn't have the tassel anymore and the
one in front there is indeed this has
been a ton of improvement you can see
that the one who is now defecating there
you urinating there does not even have a
Oh even the other one as well the tables
see they don't have the tassels anymore
maybe they have lost the tassels when
they started losing the hairs because of
maize because all of them don't have the
tassels anymore so it means this is one
of the results of that kind of a disease
look at that the tapes are very clean
there so it means the lost all those
nice tassel black hers
so now I am going to Apple further and
see if we can improve this sighting this
is amazing so now let's quickly go to
the Maasai Mara
where David is having the haineko
well my drive all the way here was pre
what it and we have seen a few fully
grown hyenas some couple minutes ago but
now we've found one of the mothers with
her two cubs and I might keep my voice a
bit soft was the very close to the
mother I can't see very well not sure if
they're nursing or not but this is one
of the females in a war first Kingdom
when waffles clan of a north clan of
highness
that sure she's very relaxed with us
oops
she puts her head up we had the Zebras
from the background that they could hear
and like any other mother with natural
instance when you have a baby the owner
is very lots of any sound of movement
see how duck or black the calves look an
indication to me there could be less
than three months the sport doesn't or
don't show until the captive three
months in above
very sleepy Cubs holdup guests but now
this should be out and about playing it
was pretty cool too easily you nothing I
guess
I initially learned to our brows not
very schwa and I know camp system will
be in a smaller - baby say no brain not
for a very long time with quite an issue
for Cubs or for canvas rather it tends
to maintain us for up to I in half which
is very unlike cannabis before the wind
and again remember it's a very
interactive Safari
turn on you asking with hyenas are
omnivorous and I would say hyenas are
carnivores carnivores because they will
only eat meat and the either tell on
hunt for themselves
Oh occasionally this courage but also
they be known to steal meat or kills
from other predators like lions or
leopards all highness the very good
hunters tale and by themselves but even
opportunity of stealing which cams they
have been known to do that
Taylan hyenas got wonderful hearing we
can pick a sound of lion cracking a bone
weigh like 1000 meters away your imagine
10 kilometers away and you pick a sound
of some vibration very high order
toreally got talking about cheeks
something six point two or six point
five miles picking some of even lands
going for a hunt or as soon as they can
hear them struggling the animals before
they start eating it hyenas can pick
that sound or vibration and definitely
go there
this particular clan we have seen a
number of times going to lions and
stealing the kill there's a particular
print of lions around here that's good
we know we know the pair of lions Steve
has been trying to locate we haven't
seen for a couple days and this highness
have always picked thick heel from the
OE nose and snatched the Emil what they
do they get close to the kill and the
building numbers and they intimidate
them I carries they must be very hungry
we've seen two of them background who
can hear more hyenas
I either heading home it's very tiny
cups
in cuisine because of their color being
black that's how they born and again I
say it's rather unusual to see the
mothers nothing for long
and I'm very happy all of you enjoying
this view and I hope what was her name
Linda you're still tuned on tuned in and
you're watching these cabs you are happy
when its head I might be visiting the
waffles or the North Klan and here we
are
how sleepy and how peaceful this mother
is we'll had two Cubs but once the oil
head up listen look smell an obscure
should there be an opportunity of some
food somewhere she was top nursing her
cubs and go look for some food occasion
we have seen some other senior ranking
members bring food whitey that's a very
good question and wonder Hawai she
cannot sleep while there nothing and I'm
sure she is having a bit of carnage for
a couple of seconds or minutes but like
we see that one whitey but like any you
know mother they have natural is
especially when they have very tiny Cubs
very small Cubs like this and the whole
idea is you have to be very alert I mean
even it challenges the fish who took
away the leopards or maybe other hyenas
or
Alliance because of water called
predator competition so he cannot take
any chances you see how she's looking
she's very a lot is so natural for all
animals in the wilderness when they have
the young ones they become super large
and very conscious of any sound out
there
but I think the cups my guess is they're
both nothing and maybe having local
clubs because they look so so peaceful
and how nice to see such a relationship
interesting because I was saying earlier
talking about the Heine crabs how how
long they take before they are weaned
and even when they're born they're born
with their teeth on you know they got
erupted teeth as they're born and unlike
many other Cubs of you know the
predators like lions leopards cheetahs
that I want eyes closed the hyenas upon
the eyes open which is quite something I
tried to remember the one who uses
either Procopio trying to remember that
word and very intelligent animals people
have always mistaken hyenas for thieves
and stealing other people's you know
meat and going to the farms in the
villages eating goats and sheep stock
like you know cows - but not really the
very intelligent animals
prodcut mama very good that the hyenas
are splitting the females are very
vigilant when it comes to their cubs and
it's very true
you cannot take any chances proud mama
with his hind even myself and that's why
she cannot afford to sleep for over a
minute or 30 seconds bucks she'll put
her head down and she keep an eye just
making sure all is good because of her
cubs when it respects this female here
what means such a great job to make sure
that say I was carrying my cabbages mrs.
Lupino sorry I apologize not for that
mrs. Lupino degree with you mamas should
not sleep and I'm to know all Mama's out
here in the wilderness even for female
lion you know and for female lions
elephants zebra any animal that will
have you know a small room smaller
little young when they never sleep I
agree with you be sleeping
100%
they must have been very hungry and it
has also been said hyenas milk is lots
of you know Blosser
Carlos protein is one of the most
nutritious milk in the world alright I
think Steve today is getting lucky lucky
with Szabo's yes look at what we found
this is maybe even the relaxed female
that we saw before look at this
servile spot to do in the road up ahead
those beautiful bright eyes I don't know
if it's a female honest he couldn't tell
you right now but it's a very relaxed
but it might also be due to the fact
that we have no lights on the vehicle is
switched off look how delicately it
moves through the long grass Taz legs
easily being placed in little spots
knows exactly where to place them and
like a typical cat back leg goes where
front foot was before is scanning the
terrain short stubby tail
mrs. Anna it's always stalking the thing
is is that it's not really necessarily
hunting a particular animal like a lion
or leopard would do it's moving through
the long grass waiting for something to
move something to flick a tail or an ear
or rustle some grass so it's moving
through very delicately so that
obviously its own movements don't give
away any sound which would impede its
own hearing and anything that gives away
the slightest of sort of sounds will be
pounced upon moving the ears from side
to side delicately once some prayers
detector that would then go into a
little bit more of a deliberate sort of
posture probably bunching the back legs
up like we see leopards do and then
launching hello I wonder if she knows
she's a star right now
beautiful camerawork via James the
fourth servo of the afternoon Kathy I'm
not aware of them being endangered or
any risk they are quite common and
popular up here in these grassy sort of
landscapes which is tone to see them I
mean the other two that we for three
we've seen this evening were very very
hard to spot and they disappeared quite
quickly but in this landscape you can
imagine how many they probably are
moving in and around but they lack these
open grasslands but yes most invariably
in areas where there are people and
poaching is a problem then I suppose
their numbers do decline because there
could potentially be a problem for for
chickens and for small lamb
and things in agricultural areas so I
don't think they do very well in high
populated areas with people but just
like that in the serval cat has
disappeared well that was a marvelous
spot and while we've been navigating
herds and herds of all the beasts and we
had another bat-eared Fox but anyway all
of the ears are out this evening and it
seems like David's hyena are having some
fun
well done Steve hopefully we'll get
another servo cut before you get home
but what you just found out now is
Bungay he's the commander in chief have
Justin arrived and now he's getting all
the warm welcome all the greetings or
the red carpet oh wife was to come back
home I don't know where she's been and
she's hiding in a little bush just kick
him out then she disappeared again and
you see all the tails of these fighters
are up and the vanity waffles any time
now a very creepy way of greetings from
the Highness obviously gonna turn around
but such a nice welcome they have given
her
when our force won't - offers to step
forward well that's the ritual they go
through and they tend to raise the leg
and there she is
even if I know controls his yeah or
force in an even when we stow it boom
they sweat before me like yeah that's
were force and she has arrived in style
you know that smooth ritual to welcome
off his back you can see how she's
respected awarded submission going on
there
from all these other females I'm sure
maybe giving her some feedback all this
world comes a fire welcome back we
missed you the air offers walks and this
is the leader of this clan
my name is Rufus and with some
researchers here from Michigan
University of Michigan State University
gas that have you know followed them for
a very long time and they have been
naming this highness or they have a
nomenclature from something of food
ruffles mace soup
and the other day I was talking you
should start comparing the Highness here
and behind us in JAMA
I can see that I have got a cookie and
the cup at the moment here any tumor
after watching a lovely I know it comes
by the Maasai Mara look at that
it's time now for the little one to be
observed missing the little one is Kali
so when the mother is doing that
grooming the little one helps with the
blood circulation and activate the
reproductive organs and the excretory
organs as well
[Music]
so these two are the oldest third and
the one for cookie is a smallest so the
little ones are so inquisitive so this
little ones are so inquisitive and if
you just being curious and quaking
everywhere checking what's happening
here so they are not aware of what is
happening here at the moment
hyenas sometimes they come close the
others come close to the cars and pies
tires
so you can see that now the listening to
that so the little one is trying to call
so this little ones when they're
learning when they are playing together
with the others is when they are
learning how to survive so they have
been moved around for quite a long time
I think now is the third of the first
time they are moving from one den to the
next sometimes going back to the similar
tan so they can be nomadic when they're
having their cups but all this is
happening for the safety of their little
ones when they're in the den they assess
the availability of fleas and parasites
if it's getting too much they know the
little ones are going to suck they are
going are going to suffer they must move
them and when this development of smell
then they must have to move the little
ones
for this little ones are looking very
healthy look at that and therefore they
must be drinking too much so but when
you see the little ones healthy like
this it means the mothers and they are
eating quite a lot of made healthy meat
today
coquí's curve is not showing dominance I
think she's thirsty is drinking too much
from the mother at the moment
listen here
that is cookies
oh she's making a very and lovely called
a suckling at the moment and she's just
whistling at the same time
allora
indeed this is amazing look at this
little ones they are so very happy and
this is one of those great sightings
look at that now Koki is looking at us
and the little one is trying to press
the mammary gland so that she can be
able to get quite a lot of milk coming
out
so the Hyannis milk has got quite a lot
of protein content and is the is one of
those iconic was or can be able to
circle the little ones up to 18 mile
that is quite a lot
so look at the structure of this animal
so now we are going to give you this a
sighting from a fully thermal camera
don't get surprised don't change the
settings from the TVs this is from us we
are just show you the animal from a
camera which detects the heat signatures
your settings by the TVs are not wrong
so look at that so you can see that
these animals and they have been very
hot during the afternoon because where
you see that the animal it looks very
bright it means the temperature is high
and where is yellow it means it's very
very high so you can see underneath the
stomach is yellow and by the ears and
here the amp it is telling you that that
is where now the body of this animal is
very much hot and the blue colors on the
ground is telling you that the
temperature is very much minimal so
maybe now this little ones are just now
well fed before the others move a way to
go and look for something to eat
actually this is one of those great
sightings I am really enjoying this
sighting at the moment so this little
one has got a big house you see that
house there next to the adult if you
look at that termite mound next to the
adults that is where they are staying is
a very big house and that house is very
much safe the problem is this house is
used by the animals as a timeshare today
we have got the inners tomorrow
what Turks are staying there after that
is gonna serve as the den for another
specie as well so when the little ones
are there they are also at high risk
because the other predators such as wall
dogs if they discover the dens they look
for them
and kill them so just to minimize the
just to minimize the Predators in the
area so competition is too high has got
nothing to do with territoriality is
about the competition of food
if Steve has got another server at the
moment Steve is leading in terms of the
several sightings I'll call you mr. self
on these days do you indeed this is the
fifth server we have seen this evening
so as far as what we've spotted from the
road these animals are certainly not
endangered in the Mara on that so this
calling me mrs. Cyril shame citizen oh
you're quite jealous of us seeing their
service but you'll get your opportunity
I'm sure my friend and it's one of those
cats you just got to go to the right
habitat and you will find them and well
this is clearly the right place and well
this one seeming there's been a little
bit more resting no it's up oh hello
service Steve I think you are is the
typical cat stretch I definitely was
having a bit of a rest and now it's
going to slink away into the long grass
isn't that a beautiful sight lovely
patterns spots rings on the tail and
long stripes on the back of the neck
provide the perfect camouflage for a cat
that lives in Long grasslands
gorgeous well as it moves slowly way out
of the IR spectrum yet again RB it
indeed well we this is what is happening
the spotlight is assisting obviously and
there's beautiful emerald shining eyes
are what stand out for us in the
darkness and well as we see our last
servile depart into the thickets day of
the long grass David is still with at
the North Glen
well I think Steve has heard he's more
sighting of Surakarta
today than any other day of his life I
won't confirm that in him
during dinner time and our cabbagey are
still nothing either apart from the last
thing that getting the wonderful want
from their mother because they have
remained in that position for the last
half an hour how beautiful is this and
how piece was this I'm sure in one model
as well as most of the sunset you can
just tweet hashtag Safari live and tell
me David that is peaceful that is very
cool not so epic heavenly as some of the
ones they got earlier magic Chris such a
nice mother
and this enhances her bond with her
young cubs and it will carefully one of
our legs I guess is just holding the
club in position I think the front right
leg Thank You Bungay what a nice mother
very complex to understand when they go
through Sibley side where one cup tends
to dominate the other and unfortunately
sometimes who get one losing sea life
and one survival sorry I'm a mr. touch
heartwarming mr. Sano thank you very
much agree with you it is I mean just
warms them there and the hearts come
very very close it's very hard woman and
this is exacting it has given me a very
good end of the day and you go up
Crystal South Africa and from myself and
boom gay goodbye from the Mara triangle
you can see there is a big competition
between juma and Masai Mara at the
moment so the juma Dan the Juma clan is
suckling and by the Maasai Mara there
was also not nessam so you can see that
now ours they wants to take over and at
the moment the cups for pretty got
disappeared to the other side maybe now
Preeti is giving the cup some orders
that you have to remain in the den I'm
just about to leave now and you can see
now good cookie and the cub also they
are very relaxed it has been a lovely
afternoon and coupled with quite a lot
of sightings all the way from the Maasai
Mara in Kenya as well as year in South
Africa by the western side of the
greater Kruger National Park thank you
very very much for all your questions
and commands we are going to meet again
tomorrow morning we are going to carry
on and bring you the best world life
experience ever